Hi, I'm Andy.
>> And I'm Rachel.
>> And welcome to Introductory Algebra Review. If you've
taken algebra class before but just need a quick review.
>> Or if you want to prepare for math
placement test, this course is a great place to start.
>> Now, if you've never taken an algebra class before, this is not the course
for you. We're just going to provide a
quick review of some of the important concepts.
>> We'll cover basic operations like
multiplication, division, exponents. Onto fractions and
decimals, ratios and rates. Algebraic expressions and
equations, and ending with a bit of graphing.
You can go at your own pace
and skip through material you're already comfortable with.
>> This course will give you a quick refresher,
helpful examples and a lot of practice problems. Enroll today.
[BLANK_AUDIO]